One thing that's a lot of fun to do in physics is to create fun problems for yourself.
For no other reason, just to see if you can solve them and to see how a system might behave.
Here we've created a problem for ourselves.
This problem involves two masses connected by a string over a pulley.
This mass is on a plane which is inclined at some angle α
Let's call acceleration positive when this mass goes up and this one goes down into the right.
Bause the other way, acceleration would be negative.
Now, I'm not going to ask you to solve for the acceleration of this system.
Maybe you could do it. Maybe not but what I want you to do is not solve.
Yet still answer this question, and the purpose of this question is to build your physics intuition.
Now, the way you're going to solve this question is by filling in these four boxes.
The blue boxes, you'll fill in with either a 1 or a 2 to indicate whether the appropriate mass
in that section of the equation is mass 1 or mass 2.
The purple boxes you'll fill in with a plus sign or a minus sign.
Now, what I want you to do is to really think about this problem
and think in your head and maybe test some limiting cases.
So for example, what happens if the M₂ is huge and M₁ is really small, maybe 0?
What happens if M₁ is really big and M₂ is close to 0?
What do you expect the acceleration to look like in those cases?
Enter your best solution in these boxes.
So for example, if you thought this was the answer, you'd enter a 1, a plus sign, a 2, and a plus sign.
Go ahead, give this some thought, and see if you can accurately fill in those boxes.